does Maga care more about democracy or
gas prices or maybe more accurately does
Maga care more about democracy or the
promise of lower gas prices when the
current gas prices aren't even very high
a version of this question is what
Chauncey De Vega asks in a very good new
commentary in Salon called is America
ready to trade democracy for cheap gas
that's fascism in a nutshell Americans
understand rights chaunceyed that
democracy is in dire Peril that doesn't
mean they believe in it or give a damn I
encourage you to check out this piece
written yesterday
he references the New York Times
headline which says voters see democracy
in Peril but saving it isn't a priority
he writes the details are Grim voters
quote overwhelmingly believe American
democracy is under threat but seem
remarkably apathetic about that danger
with relatively few calling it the
nation's most pressing problem
more than one-third of independent
voters in the poll said they were open
to supporting candidates who reject the
legitimacy of the 2020 election because
economic concerns are more urgent 71
percent agreed democracy was at risk
only seven percent said it was the most
important problem in the country so one
of the important things to consider is
that for many of these Maga voters it's
the promise of lower gas prices which
they're willing to trade for democracy
for the will of the people depending who
is in office but when you look at gas
prices you say they're not even really
that high they're down like 30 something
percent from the peak and for the
average vehicle even if they were to go
down another 30 percent you're only
talking about quite literally a few
dollars difference for every full tank
that couldn't really be worth trading
for a functioning democracy could it but
it appears that for many voters indeed
it is and so we are down to the very end
here as it comes to the 2022 midterms uh
we're going to have results starting
Tuesday night and I hope you'll be live
with me on YouTube twitch and Facebook
the 2022 midterms may be just the
beginning in fact they almost certainly
will be just the beginning we will
probably learn in the 24 to 48 hours
that follow Tuesday's elections
if and how committed are
right Wingers to democracy 2020
suggested the answer is not particularly
committed but we will see very quickly
are they doing this if we won it was
fair but if we lost its rigged thing are
they going to do it again and if they do
it will be a sign that it is now just
sop standard operating procedure for
these folks and that will be yet another
divot in the Democracy that is left at
this point in time I don't know that
they do care about democracy at this
point anymore
uh I think that at this point they just
want to win now we also just want to win
but we want to win by people realizing
their ideas are a disaster we're not
trying to win by just putting in office
people who got fewer votes that is a
critical fundamental difference you
might think the top tax rate should be
38 percent
and you might think it's 42 and I might
think it's 43 and those are reasonable
differences that exist in in reality
but if one of us believes that actually
if my candidate gets fewer votes we
should figure out a way to install them
anyway
that is very different than a
disagreement about about tax policy or
foreign policy or whatever the case may
be I hate I hate the fact that the
answer to Is America ready to give up
democracy because they have been
convinced cheaper gas is more expect
more important I am afraid that the
answer is indeed yes and we will know
much more about that what 72 hours from
now one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa I have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs I have not one but
two all form sofas I've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable Furniture I own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and arm chairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below